تخيلوا ماذا سيحدث لو فشلت الشمس بعضا من
غضبها واطلقت القليل من رياحها باتجاه
كوكبنا خصوصا بعد اكتشاف ثقب عملاق ثاني
في هالتها بحجم يفوق حجم الارض 20 مره فهل
تشكل هذه الثقوب خطوره على كوكبنا الثقوب
الاكليليه هي مناطق يكون فيها الغلاف
المحيط بالشمس اي الهاله ابرد من المعتاد
وتظهر بسبب اختلالات طبيعيه في المجال
المغناطيسي للشمس هذه الثقوب تسمح للرياح
الشمسيه التي هي عباره عن جسيمات مشحونه
بالطاقه بالهروب بسهوله اكبر الى الفضاء
وقد تتفاعل مع غلاف الارض المغناطيسي
مسببه ظاهره الشفق القطبي او تؤثر على
مسار المركبات الفضائيه لكن على عكس
الكثير من المنشورات على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي التي تهول الامر وتدعي ان الارض
ستحترق بلهيب الشمس نتيجه لهذه الثقوب
خلال الايام المقبله فان الرياح الشمسيه
عاده ما تمر بسلام وفق الخبراء الا اذا
كانت هذه الرياح قويه جدا وحينها قد تؤثر
على عمل الاقمار الصناعيه او تدمرها اما
بالنسبه للارض فيمكنها تعطيل موجات
الراديو واحداثيات نظام تحديد المواقع
العالمي